aujourd'hui vous présente le dernier
casque à réduction de bruit de bosses en
partenariat avec boulanger c'est une
vidéo que j'ai tourné il ya déjà
quelques mois au mois de mars que je
vais vous diffuse que maintenant je vous
ramène donc d'en passer à new york pour
les découvrir le dernier castarède son
bruit de bosses on est aujourd'hui à
l'aéroport charles de gaulle à paris je
parle doucement parce que je suis dans
le launch d'air france quatre autres
bruits je veux vous testez vos copines
c'est ce cas là dedans je sais pas si
vous vous intéressez d'audio si vous
connaissez un nouveau casque de bois
joly d'être là je voulais voir que ces
deux retours dans l'avion lors d'un
grand voyage mais pour tester je vous
emmène aujourd'hui je contourne y en a
aux commentaires j'entends ça
[Musique]
fraîchement sortie d'avion vraiment pro
à new york
on va se parler aujourd'hui si
l'affichage qui décolle on va se parler
aujourd'hui d'un voilà ah bah ça va on
va se tester un casque j'ai dans mon sac
derrière ici on va parler d'année casque
bose je vais vous donner plein plein
plein de retours de tester tous les
côtés qui fâchent même chose à vous dire
vous allez voir franchement il est pas
mal
elliott c'est pas un lit ici c'est pas
non c'est pas les bons à 30 cm un café
vient d'un monde comment tu crois bien
qu'on les deux opus jossic pour vous par
les audiophiles trouve un spot
emblématique un truc vraiment incroyable
et j'ai un spot emblématique officines
ça vous parle ça c'est lower manhattan
je pas si vous connaissez un peu de
grosses tours c'est le one world trade
center et vous avez tout le district
financier brooklyn qui s'est eu de ce
côté là bas avec le brooklyn bridge mais
lydie tout de suite c'est effectivement
pas vous faire une petite balade
touristique de new york lorsque vous
parlez d'audio de vous parler du nouveau
casque de bosses avec la statue de la
liberté qui est juste là
[Musique]
shalev dans une boîte cesse d'expliquer
cuir c'est plutôt pas mal passé
qualitatif en fait et quand vous
l'ouvrez le casque présente comme ça
vous avez votre petit casque homme sage
et vous détaille dans quelques instants
que vous avez juste trapy sylla qui
cache en fait de petits accessoires le
tout premier c'est de l'usb sévère de
l'usb pour venir recharger un peu ce
temps là et le deuxième c'est ça c'est
jack jack
si vous regardez vous en avait un qui
est plus grand c'est le plus petit qui
se branche dans le casque et c'est le
plus grand il va se brancher à tout ce
que vous voulez on écouteurs un baladeur
dans la première chose c'est le confort
alors je sais nager une touche avec le
bonnet les lunettes mais il fait chaud
il fait france sait pas quel temps il
fait ici en fait on va se poser sa cote
de sang la tronche d'un petit chat tu te
caches là c'est le confort alors confort
il est quand même plutôt pas mal pour ne
pas reconnaître qu'on a de la petite
mousse à mémoire de forme sur le côté on
l'a également sur le dessus aussi
qui fait qu' on a un casque qui est
quand même assez confortable qui prend
bien les oreilles lorsque vous le porter
pendant des heures notamment dans un
avion vous sentez un petit point de
pression je vous conseille quand même de
devenir bien l'ouvrir pour que ça appuie
pas trop et si ça crie ça vous embête
qu'elle est un petit peu à l'avant au
pire un poil à l'arrière ça marche
beaucoup mieux ça va bien ça c'est un
coulissant en fait je leur femme et je
fus coulisser dessus ce qui fait que
j'ai pas de comptage et qu'au final
c'est assez facile à manipuler par
contre vous le voyez à l'intérieur il ya
écrit right left ce qui fait que ça
c'est vraiment face à l'avant lorsque
vous le tenez sur vous et vous pouvez
pas le faire mais d'un autre côté ça
bloque tout instant culturels entre le
truc qui est assez impressionnant c'est
que toute la structure a été construite
par gustave eiffel et on voit
l'intérieur comment c'est fait c'est
complètement incroyable et a bien
évidemment c'est tout qui résout par
bartholdi vraiment fait comment c'est
fait 5 à ce qui est vraiment super
légers tous faim tout discret réponse
assez lâche rien et ya un point qui est
vraiment génial c'est le côté tactique
parce qu'il ya des cas ce qu'on galère
entre pas forcément est là vous trouvez
vous le posez vous appuyez avant tac ses
plaies vous appuyer ses poses pareil
raconte j'ai décroché morceaux suivants
morceaux précédents vous montez vous
montez le son vous baissez vous baissez
le son ça c'est génial c'est hyper
intuitive sans scapula vous avez en fait
trois boutons premier bouton qui situe
la cène voudront pour l'allumer pour les
peindre vous allez pouvoir aussi de
synchroniser en nous tous extrêmement
facilement le bouton cas là c'est pour
le connecter avec les google assistant
avec amazon avec ça et lorsque vous êtes
sur iphone vous avez également syrie et
vous avez ici un petit bouton qui est
bien tout en un est de régler votre
réduction de bruit vous pouvez choisir
de mettre réduction de bruit à 10 qui à
fond à 5 qui est moyen oient 0 vous la
supprimer pour bien évidemment ça aussi
réglé depuis l'application
mais une fois de plus je voulais montrer
tout à l'heure on a donc un design qui
est sobre qui est simple qui est élégant
que moi personnellement j'aime bien je
trouve vraiment vraiment léger et ça
c'est vraiment un point extrêmement
positif lorsqu'on l'a autour de son cou
on oublie très très rapidement et bien
évidemment c'est un cas ce que veut dire
charger en usb c
une application qui est assez simple à
utiliser c'est celle là la bonne musique
donc voyez là il s'est connecté je vois
bien mon casque c'est mon boss nc 700
greu là j'en trouve avec les quelques
informations vous avoir au niveau de mon
casque le nombre d'heures restantes
bollaërt source paramètres la réduction
du bilan pour moi c'était vraiment
intéressant natus à pouvoir régler votre
réduction de bruit que vous choisissez
10 c'est la réduction de bruit maximal 0
c'est la réduction de bruit complètement
désactivé et après vous choisissez ce
que vous voulez vous ne réglez ici
d'autres paramètres vous pouvez
mémoriser vos derniers réglages donc
toute la partie réduction brute elle est
extrêmement intuitif facile à utiliser
ça c'est plutôt cool
l'application est pas mal vous avez
votre identifiant vos produits vos
informations les notifications ce que je
vaux 4 simplication par contre annoncé
de ne pas avoir des croiseurs quel
meilleur endroit pour vous parler de
casques à réduction de bruit que de me
faire dire on entame scolaire le temple
où il ya du bruit de la lumière tout le
temps le permanence et que vous pouvez
faire ce que vous voulez pas mettre un
casque s'il ya du bruit ya du bruit sauf
qu'avec un bon casque à réduction de
bruit ça peut franchement arranger la
faire ça peut vous sembler un peu
l'histoire et vous permette vraiment
profiter d'une meilleure qualité audio
alors justement laissez moi vous parler
d'autres ce casque là il a une signature
qui est très particulière il ya certes
un casque qui ont des sont un petit peu
trop agressif ou alors trop plat celui
là il apporte quelque chose de très
différent
il est un petit peu relevé dans le
médias parce que ça lui apporte c'est un
petit peu d'agressivité un petit peu
plus de côté rock'n'roll lorsque vous
allez venir écouter des guitares sont un
peu rock ça fait ressortir les voies et
fait sa marque moi personnellement
j'aime beaucoup
j'écoute de la guitare feront vraiment
l' attaque des guitares le son est cool
le spectre est vraiment bon on n'est pas
sur ensemble qui agresse on est vraiment
sur son cool mais qui du coup va type et
le casque du coup ce que je pouvoir
regretter c'est qu'effectivement ça
manque un peu
base pour réhausser tous à y apporter un
peu de peps c'est d'un groove est un peu
derrière ça c'est un peu la limite un
peu du truc mais à côté de ça ça fait le
taf c'est vraiment bon une fois de plus
j'aurais eu un équaliseur dans
l'application bord est extrêmement alors
rassurez-vous peu comme avoir un
équaliseur vous allez dans les
applications que vous utilisez pour la
musique
si vous êtes sur spotify vous avez un
petit est co-leader vous venez et on
s'est légèrement les basses sont en
train de donner un son un peu plus rond
il ya un autre point qui est vraiment
cool et qui part à porter notamment sur
un casque comme ça c'est la
spatialisation lorsque vous mettez votre
caste sur nos oreilles forcément ça
vient que vous enfermez et lorsque vous
vous écoutez de la musique c'est
important c'est que vous ayez pas un son
un petit peu les tripes et trop petit
là ça vous ou est vraiment une vraie
belle spécialisation trouve que bosse
dessus a fait aussi un excellent état
désolé pour le dos jamais dans un
endroit il ya beaucoup de pouvoir se
rendre compte un petit peu juste moi
parce qu'on parle le café réduction
brute dont il faut du bruit et là les
systèmes scolaires il ya beaucoup de
bruit
la spécialisation est vraiment cool
lorsque vous écoutez de choses pour
trouver un petit peu je tiens
l'instrument qui dans tel endroit
l'autre instrumenté par l'avons trouvé
vraiment le mix en tout cas qui a été
fait à l'ingénieur du son il ya un autre
bloc est extrêmement important sur cette
typologie de casque c'est l'autonomie
pense que si vous avez un son qui est
bien et bordélique son bruit mais il te
donne et qui tient pas franchement vous
n'allez pas bien loin
et justement l'aide suppose aussi bien
bosser vous aide à les jeux par
brouillard bêtise chevaux aux alentours
de 18h alors si vous aller couper la
réduction de bruit vous allez bien venir
d'autonomie mais comme ça déjà ça fait
le taff 18 ans vous êtes tranquille
vous n'allez pas garder un truc comme ça
pendant 18 ans sur les oreilles si par
contre vous avez quand même profité
d'une bonne réduction de brouille
j'ai voulu garder vous et parlons de
recharge et moi par exemple j'ai fait
paris new york je suis à huit heures et
qui sait pouvoir faire devant le retour
sans aucun problème en présence des
coûts de la musique
donc c'est quand même relativement
peinard et si j'ai besoin je le branche
jeu leur charge très rapide on pouvoir
partir en écoutant de la musique
facilement rapidement donc rennes pour
ça aussi très bon point pour hbo pour
moi ce casque il est très cool mais il a
deux défauts majeurs le premier la
réduction de bruit elle est bonne mais
elle n'est pas complètement parfaite est
pas complètement idéal ça vous corrige
vraiment ça n'est vraiment réduire le
bruit ambiant lorsque vous à l'écouté de
la musique
j'ai notamment testé dans l'avion où il
fait abstraction des lieux extrêmement
bruyant lorsque vous le mettez ça fait
tâche
vous le mettez sur dix la réduction de
bruit est bonne le prix d'achat est
mauvaise elle est vraiment très bonne
mais par rapport à ce qu'on trouve
ailleurs il manque pas grand chose
maintenant il ya un deuxième point ça
j'ai constaté aussi dans l'avion vos
oreilles elles sont bien tenues par les
écouteurs mais peut-être qu'ils manquent
rip un tout petit peu d'épaisseur de
plus au niveau de l'anus pourquoi tout
simplement parce que lorsque vous le
tenez comme ça sur les oreilles il faut
bouger légèrement même un tout petit peu
dans l'avion avait quand même capter le
bruit environnant nous avions capté le
bruit extérieur c'est pas idéal c tpat
extrêmement grave n'est pas pondre y est
vous bouger un petit peu tout ce que
vous entendez le bruit et ça occupe pas
complètement tactile manque pas grand
chose je pense qu'une toute petite
épaisseur au niveau des coûts signer
pour ça vienne couper et que ce soit
complètement optimale rien
dans le détail c'est pas grand chose
mais c'est l'âge et à côté de ça c'est
un cast qui est vraiment cool que je
trouve très très bon la qualité sonore
j'adore j'adore ce mordant au niveau des
guitares vous mettez un bon vieux ac dc
os que vous voulez ça répond tout de
suite le tout petit peu de customisation
au niveau des basses safra tacle
autonomie est bonne la qualité de la
réduction bruit et quand même vraiment
cool on va pas se mentir c'est pas des
cas ce que les moins chers du marché
mais à côté de ça c'est parce qu'on a
cherché en marche et le très haut de
gamme le premium de chez boseret dessus
pour moi c'est un excellent casque vous
voulez un très bon casque avec son bruit
que vous aimez laissons un petit peu
mordant un petit peu rock'n roll eh bien
vous ne louperez pas avec cette cascade
chez bose
moi j'ai beaucoup plaisir en tout cas a
été jetée à l'écouté une balle a dit
avec à prendre l'avion et je sens le
trajet retour hyper cool et une fois de
plus ici à times square ce soir il ya
beaucoup ball et me remettre la up
il est allumé moi j'ai la réduction
proactive qui a dit stop montant
quasiment pas parlé ça
dans ma tête j'entends au loin les
sirènes c'était très fort j'ai la
musique qui est là c'est cool
voyez comme ça c'est un casque et très
urbain ou bien vous balader en ville
comme ça fait vraiment vous ne réglez
vraiment à votre oreille facilement
comme vous voulez ça marche
sur un mouvement comme ça ça me dérange
pas c'est vraiment dans l'avion fait
doyer cette soufflerie qu'on attend
derrière mais là ça fait le taf
j'suis pas dérangé par la position
justement ça tient très bien sur la tête
très léger on sent pas on n'a pas de
point là il sera extrêmement facilement
vous toucher légèrement comme ça pour
moi c'est très très bon casque
[Musique]
je pose sa voix là finit là dessus je
pense que vous pensez avoir commentaires
que ça vous convient et je vous montre
vite fait la vue de la chambre c'est
incroyable en fait il eu sur thème
scolaire qui très coûteux sur ce mark et
moi ce que vous en pensez en dans
commentaires des commentaires des lights
que voulez vous savez comme d'habitude
sur ce je vous embrasse dans les volutes
de main pour continuer bien évidemment
demain ou après demain par l'etec les
vidéos
[Musique]